la france à l'heure américaine après les
feuilletant la musique est depuis peu le
basket voici l'arrivée en force de
halloween cette fête traditionnelle créé
en irlande et qui fait les beaux jours
des enfants citrouilles sorcières et
fantômes made in france
eric lemasson physique jaffelin cet
automne dans les vitrines et dans les
jardins fleurissent les citrouilles et
danse des sorcières car voilà halloween
qui surgit sans crier gare au beau
milieu de notre tradition la fête
d'halloween vous connaissez halloween
j'en ai entendu parler halloween
c'est une fête parmi les cas ça oui
là-bas chaque 31 octobre
les enfants se déguisent pour rencontrer
les revenants demander des bonbons aux
voisins tout en jouant à se faire peur
séduite par cette idée la maman d'arthur
et cannelle à décorer la maison déguisés
les enfants aient décidé d'inscrire
halloween en bonne place dans le
calendrier familial car les enfants
adorent tout ce qui est horrible
surtout quand c'est pour defour bien sûr
y'a pas grand chose entre mardi gras et
elle fait un bon moyen s'étaler de de
fêter halloween de leurs aussi de
démystifier le monde des sorcières des
monstres de dracula excellent ce qu'eux
mêmes se déguisent et c'est même toute
l'école qui fêtera avec eux cette fête
païenne
les commerçants se frottent les mains
des milliers de français se déguiseront
ce soir sans que l'on sache très bien
l'origine de cet engouement
faudrait-il y voir une habile manoeuvre
bassement commerciales de l'oeil qui
colle à 5 francs jusqu'à la citrouille à
400 francs voilà une nouvelle occasion
de faire ouvrir les portes monnaies
cette année ça prend une proportion
énorme
nous sommes sur des peines de chiffre
d'affaires d'environ 1000 francs par
jour les enfants viennent en bande
s'amusent se déguisent et essaye et les
publicitaires à l'affût n'ont pas manqué
de repérer le potentiel de la fête de la
citrouille
même si halloween est encore assez
méconnue maintenant grâce au mélange des
cultures et puis tous ces films
américains qu'on regarde souvent où on
sait ce que c'est même si on a une idée
à peu près approximative on conserve
après ce que c'est je crois pas qu'on
prenne un grand risque
on s'inscrit dans une nouvelle fête et
pour nous c'est bien existé au début de
quelque chose et c'est ainsi que pour
vendre des téléphones mobiles 8500
citrouilles ont été posés dans les
jardins du trocadéro
comment savoir si c'est la tradition
d'halloween qui s'installe en france où
si les as du marketing veulent nous
faire prendre des citrouilles pour des
lanternes
quoi qu'il en soit à rungis le cours de
la citrouille a grimpé de 12%